[Music]
hey everybody what's going on damn i'm
over here
what are you doing in the other people's
video what happened spock
he's not even on camera
oh so he moved the camera pookie did it
somebody moved the camera she was
jumping up here earlier i just didn't
notice somebody moved the camera yeah
pookie did it
good
she must have been up here when i yeah
well she jumped up here
like probably like about 10 minutes ago
okay and i had to
usher her off
because she's like what i want to stomp
all over your keyboard
there it is all right yeah i thought you
were just going to move the camera
she's up here well she [ __ ] around up
here i think like when i'm not looking
you know what i mean
yeah and this looks like this might be a
little bit a little crooked
these are not the same these legs are
not the same size
this is technical difficulties people
yeah what else is technical difficulties
our whole lives are technical
difficulties
that's how it feels to be sometimes all
right i always have some [ __ ] going
wrong with whatever the [ __ ] it is but
yeah so i think uh i vaguely remember on
friday night sidetrack show that we were
talking about how we should do some more
really older horror and classic horror
which i've actually wanted to be wanted
to do for like a long time now and i
think king kong was one of the ones that
we brought up
so
when we were scrolling through movies
last night um you know not gonna lie tom
had been at the bar all day
uh so yeah because i was like well do
you want to do godfather too and he was
like i'm too drunk to like follow that
it's like too long
so
i was like okay so i go on hbo max and i
was like scrolling through there and i'm
like oh they have the original king kong
and we said that we wanted to do that
and i've been wanting to revisit it so i
said king kong it is that's like very
very easy to follow we had just brought
it up so yes it's fun movie it is very
fun and honestly this is actually
i i think it would be difficult to
overstate
how
groundbreaking this film is in like lots
and lots of different ways not just in
the special effects which of course are
mind-blowing for the time i mean people
in the 30s they must have [ __ ] a brick
when they saw this [ __ ] movie yeah
well there's some good stuff there's
some good shots
composite shots
where you have
fay-ray
live-action struggling inside a tree and
there's a tree behind her behind there
there's a stop-motion kong that reaches
down and grabs her and it
it looks real good for the 30s it looks
real good
so you got live action and
and uh
stop motion happening in in the same
frame i mean they used a lot of and
actually they they had like a lot of new
technique like they pioneered a lot of
techniques i mean obviously like all of
the you know kong and the dinosaurs and
everything like that or stop motion
but they also did a lot of like rear
projection they did a lot of like
compositing they did a lot of different
stuff they would have a thing where
they'd have like an animated like a
stop-motion animated sequence like kong
is like doing some [ __ ] up here and then
like down here there'd be like a cave
and then there'd be like a miniature
screen in there that was showing like
some footage that they'd shot of the
actors so they did like all kind of
tricks like that and i think like a lot
of the matte paintings and stuff were
great too because
a lot of them like they did them on
glass so they were kind of like uh you
know layered
you know and so it looked like there was
like a lot of depth of field and like
looked really good and i had forgotten i
mean i saw this movie when i was a kid i
don't think i've sat through the whole
thing like since then
but when i was watching it i was like
man i forgot how [ __ ] violent this
supermarket was
super violent i'm like god damn it it
doesn't pull any punch
so many people get killed yeah calm
reaching over there and grabbing one of
the damn tribal dudes from the [ __ ]
island and just biting him
spit his mouth
later on he just reaches in and sees a
woman he thinks it's he thinks it's his
girlfriend fred ray he just looks at her
and she's and he's looking at her no
it's not her just tosses her
she's ah
i mean that was horrifying i'm glad i'm
super scared of heights so yeah so that
like really
[ __ ] i mean some people might look at
this movie and go man this is terrible
it's all you know they're abusing these
animals and it's all racist and
everything that is exact you're totally
misreading this movie it is saying
exactly the opposite
it's saying you can't go around and just
[ __ ]
killing all these giant animals
doing whatever you want and you can't go
to some island and where there's another
culture of people there and because
they're not as technologically advanced
as you doesn't mean that you can control
kong okay because when they got kong
back to new york he [ __ ] them up too
okay i mean but the thing about it
though was that i mean when they did
bring him to civilization which they
should not have done yes uh
he actually did get destroyed which was
sad but like i said he did nothing wrong
that's what i'm saying did nothing wrong
that's what slasher fred is saying who
do you think was the villain carl denham
or kong himself the human well khan
can't be a villain because he's just
doing what kong do yeah i mean he
doesn't know any different he was king
of his own island he ran it and they
captured him i mean the natives that
lived on the island were kind of like
living in i mean they had to sacrifice
somebody every now and then yeah but
they were kind of living in an uneasy
peace with all the other animals they
kind of like worked some [ __ ] out yeah
and then you know suddenly like all
these dumb ass like [ __ ] white new
ones
stumble into this island and be like i
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna put
this guy in the in a movie and yeah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
all this other stuff and they [ __ ]
over they [ __ ] up how'd that work out
they [ __ ] over they [ __ ] over the
tribal people and kong by breaking this
covenant that they had they had a system
worked out
and these guys show up says ah now you
know we've got gas bombs and machine
guns and
you know ships and technology and you
know
the dude literally comes out and says he
says kong's going to learn to fear us
and and you know but yeah he says that
in the movie and carl was going to learn
when i was like jesus christ you know
what he's going to learn to fear us and
and and be under our control no didn't
work out that way didn't work out you
learned the same lessons that those
natives learned just because you got a
big old city full of skyscrapers you're
just like those people that i mean kong
can still step on you yeah
[Laughter]
he's just a uh uh um
he's a uh
he's a metaphor for uh
nature
you know that's yeah you're not gonna
really be able to
you know no matter how great you think
your city is and how good your
technology is you're not going to beat
nature
nature runs this that's that's what the
message is
yeah you don't have a right to go in
there and just start [ __ ] up people's
habitats
that's another thing that's yeah and i
definitely do think i don't know that if
carl denim and like the other people
were specifically portrayed as villains
but i think you could totally read that
into that i don't think they were
villains villains they were just like
ignorant and they were just kind of like
blundering their way in there because
they thought they knew better yeah and
it looks like to me
the the main character he's supposed to
be the hero he's dumb as [ __ ] he's dumb
as [ __ ] he wasn't actually the original
guy um that guy was actually the guy
that played the main uh love interest
dude he was actually the stunt because
i'll get into like because this actually
the the movie like the um the story
behind how this movie was made was
actually just as interesting as the
movie itself i'm not talking about that
man i'm talking about the character that
he's he's being told to play you know
what i mean well yeah but that might
have something to do with the actor
because i'm gonna say that actor was not
super experienced he was he thought that
he was being brought on as like the
stunt performer
for the actual actor but they couldn't
get the actual actor because he had to
do some other [ __ ] he's part of the
he-man women's hater club all right he's
like
yeah yeah he's the e-man woman haters oh
you women you're just you're just a
bother by your very nature
he's like spanky spanky alfalfa stymie
and all those guys from the he-man woman
haters like
yeah no i don't have no girls in here no
they're boobies yeah and then i'll say
you know underwear dude kind of love you
you love me too don't you he just goes
just that bad just that fast
and he is not much charm to the guy
and i would i the way i interpreted the
movie is that he was supposed to be kind
of a generic
yeah
guy of the 30s
thank you jeffy who's blundering his way
through this whole thing
yeah he survived
but it caused a lot of this [ __ ] in
certain way in some ways i mean yeah it
wasn't really his fault
it was more carl denham's fault yeah he
wasn't really in charge but he was just
doing what he was told which is that's
typical for the for the 30s and 40s and
50s those dudes mostly just did what
they were told you know though
he was just like the sailor like the
main sailor on the ship right way
society was you know just in the west
you know uh way guys where's a lot like
what you'd see modern china they just
kind of you know they're one fish in the
large sea and it's
just kind of everybody's kind of the
same they're all kind of generic they
were they were like that they just did
what they were told and they expected
just it'll all work out you know hey you
know the authorities will work it out
you know you know
you know [ __ ] there was like uh you
know a lot of the guys were like that
they didn't question what they were
being told or what they were doing
well i kind of feel like they saw a
dinosaur and opened fire
that's what i like yeah and i had
forgotten about that aspect of it like
literally like they get to skull island
they see a [ __ ] snake it's a
stegosaurus shoot it blitz yeah open
fire [ __ ] like he's not bothering you
he's just stegosaurus thing over there
he charged yeah you shot him
he's mad
but yeah so yeah but like i said it was
just kind of like i don't know it i i
don't know if necessarily i think the
movie was just kind of like um because
prior to king kong coming out i mean
obviously this was a massive success and
you know they made like a bunch of uh
you know they made a sequel and remakes
and everything like that
but
prior to this there had been actually
like um a big tradition of jungle films
which usually had to do you know a lot
of them were silent films or
documentaries or mockumentaries they
actually did make some documentaries
back then too
but
so it was usually kind of thing like oh
you know a big white explorer like goes
to some crazy play and then like find
some weird like [ __ ] up specimen so
this wasn't coming out of nowhere
but i do kind of feel like so i don't
know if it was necessarily like making
fun of that trope or
i don't know if making fun of it
wasn't really making fun of it but you
could totally read it as these guys just
they show up on the island and literally
just like start shooting try shooting
killing [ __ ] dinosaurs that are
absolutely that are absolutely not doing
anything yeah yeah like like i said if
the stegosaurus had like come out and
like started eating people then okay
enough it was just over there and then
source
fair
there was a thing that was something
they saw brontosaurus
i know they don't call them brontosaurus
anymore but like back then they called
it brontosaurus i'm like that's an
herbivore
yeah they start shooting its head
although it ate a dude later and i was
just like hey there's an airplane in
self-defense that's what i'm saying i
was like you had that comment yeah
that's all you had that coming and then
uh
to get there and uh to get there in the
the tribe that the the
is pretty cool they're kind of dressed
in kind of polynesian looking outfits
kind of like hawaii or [ __ ] something
like that you know it's like very
stereotypical tiki looking
design
kind of but they look good cool they had
big [ __ ] headdresses and [ __ ]
spears that their main what they called
a witch doctor he was i thought they i
thought he was looking badass he looked
good yeah his his their king he had a
big long spirit a head dress they
wouldn't show his face real clearly i
think it was a white guy in a mask no i
don't think it was because i think that
guy
and actually i was going to say like the
a large amount of the cast of this
including fay-ray and including i think
the guy that played the quote-unquote
witch doctor um they were in
uh the producer uh
mary cooper his last movie most
dangerous game which i think came out of
1932 which obviously was the was an
adaptation of that really famous short
story um had pretty much
the same cast and i think that guy was
in his name's noble something robertson
he was big he looked at about six one
six two is big he did he looked like a
big [ __ ] big dude yeah but yeah
so but but yeah so it was a lot and a
lot of the sets and stuff like that were
reused from that too like the actually
the jungle set was i think they built it
out some but that was actually built for
most dangerous game this was actually
the way that this movie was made like i
said they kind of started out like they
had the idea to do the movie like i said
they'd had all these jungle kind of
movies and it's like i don't really
think that
this movie in particular i don't think
uh particularly for the 1930s i don't
think that the way that the natives were
was portrayed were particularly racist
no but um some people have said that
there had been a tradition of these kind
of jungle movies and in particular
there's one kind of notorious one which
had come out in 1930 1931 something like
that which was called in ingagi in gaji
something like that and it very
specifically uh implied one it had white
women in blackface and two
it uh implied that black women were
having sex with monkeys and having
babies that were like half a half man
man never heard of that one so there was
that yeah from the 30s yeah
so so that kind of [ __ ] was going on so
i think actually for the time is it a
horror movie no it was like a it was
like a um i think it was like a
mockumentary it was like part
documentary in part because like i said
back in the 20s and 30s like in the
silent era and [ __ ] people were all
about
all these kind of like you know editions
expedition kind of like white explorer
goes into like darkest africa and like
finds all these creatures and like i
said they were even doing mockumentaries
back then that is absolutely not a
thing like they would shoot fake
documents yeah they would shoot real
footage but then they would like insert
some other [ __ ] and this this this this
makes sense for the time you know in the
30s you know you take a lot of [ __ ] for
granted they didn't have satellites in
the 30s they weren't sure
really how accurate the maps were it was
like a more
sophisticated version of the 1700s which
wasn't that far from the 1500s they
weren't they thought there could be
islands out there that we didn't know
about that might be like going to
another planet
so they would they would and if you went
to a place like africa i think i think
the somebody showed me
uh some things that the british had
computed based on statistics when they
were down there in the 1800s
or 1700s which one of the two remember
we were looking for dr livingston yeah
that guy
well uh the the the british corporations
who were dealing with it down there
worked out that said the average
lifespan of a [ __ ] white man down
there was league was like 16 months
that if you were running around in there
you know what i mean because there's you
know it was it was tribal territories
yeah you'd make friends but then those
friends you made had enemies they were
fighting each other
and you you you and you're and you're
white as yours stand out yeah
and they might not understand what it is
that they're seeing they might think
that you're
an evil spirit or something you know
what i mean because they had their own
religions or that you're possessed by a
demon and they'd kill you
or if they didn't really quite sure what
you were um
so you know
that go you know white boy is going to
[ __ ] econo africa back in these days
it's kind of like going to the moon a
little bit and they didn't have
television so you're trying to show
a pretty kind of simple people by
today's standards trying to show them to
pick entertaining depictions of what
it's like far away places you know
but anyway i think kong was handled
pretty well
um yeah especially like i said i've seen
some other movies from the 30s that were
way more problematic than yeah
the the um
this one was actually pretty yeah the
people are pretty tame yeah the the
black people in it are are are portrayed
as people uh bri uh they are in one
scene they're
[ __ ] bravely fighting [ __ ] kong
and dying and they're [ __ ] you know
they get eaten too just alongside the
white people so it's not
and well they're staying with kong
running and there's a little baby girl
crying he's in the path and then the mom
has to run out and [ __ ] rescue the
baby she's like just in time you know so
it's you know i mean it was they're just
portrayed as anybody else and then later
on you find out yeah
you white people are just like everybody
else cog does the same thing to you when
he gets to new york so that's kind of
the message behind the
the story
and i
and i was picked up kind of an animal
rights
message to it don't go around [ __ ]
with those animals
like that you went into their habitat
you [ __ ] killed them and then you
took one of them back to your place and
he [ __ ] you up he died but you paid
for it that's that's right anyway i mean
yeah it's clearly shown is kind of wrong
well like i said and i think even at the
time like when king kong dies at the end
spoiler alert for a movie that's almost
100 years old but um you know when he
dies at the end like people you're
supposed to feel bad yeah
i mean because he didn't do anything
it's like he like i said he was just
kong and he was doing his thing he was
doing his thing and like these dudes
blundered in and were like oh we're
gonna like put him on stage and like
make all this money off him and exploit
him and they take him away from his home
and they take him away from everything
that he knows and then they put him on
display and he's like he's like [ __ ] you
guys and bust out like you you know you
felt bad for him and like i said i think
even back then people felt bad for him
yeah i mean and the thing about it too
this movie came out
in 1933 which was like
the lowest point of the depression
really but they said that this movie
i mean there was lines around the block
they said they had to put the movie on
like 24-hour cycles like because people
were coming back to see it over and over
again oh yeah um
this was the first
i think this was like the first
quote-unquote blockbuster movie i know
that a lot of people say like you know
1975 jaws was like the first big summer
blockbuster but to be honest i think
this was actually the first what we
would term nowadays a blockbuster in the
sense that everybody went to see it
everybody was talking about it they had
to put
more showings on so people and people
were going back to see it like multiple
times people were like they loved this
[ __ ] movie so much so
that it was so successful that they that
rko i think was who made it
they um
rushed a sequel into production because
that's how they do
the sequel
son of kong which is actually like
pretty decent i haven't seen it i
haven't seen it a long time but i
remember it being pretty you've got to
see it yeah but they made it in like
what like nine months it came out the
same year [ __ ] like as soon as that was
like like real successful they were like
make another one relief really quickly
well if you've got enough money involved
with that streamlined process you could
do it yeah although i wouldn't mind
seeing it
although watching the movie there's
really only two characters in the movie
kong and fay ray
i mean everything else is kind of
interchangeable
well i think that's kind of that's why
it's good like once they get to skull
island like most of them get killed off
honestly i think my favorite scene in
the whole movie is when kong is shaking
all this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and they're all like ah they're all like
falling down at the pit and you know
what there's actually there was actually
another scene there
and i think the footage has been mostly
lost but after they all fell into the
pit as if it wasn't bad enough that they
all fell into the pit after that but
then they got attacked by like giant
spiders and eaten by giant spiders like
the ones that didn't die but the thing
about it is that this movie
i like i said i have forgotten how
[ __ ] violent this was i forgot how
many people like kong stomped on yeah
and squished i forgot how many people he
ate yeah um and that chick in new york
that he just like threw out the windows
like i was just like [ __ ] hell i was
like jesus christ
well he was sick of women he just wanted
that one but yeah well see he thought it
was her life
he thought he was like no you're not the
righteous whatever and she's like flames
she's like [ __ ]
can you imagine just be like sleep in
your [ __ ] apartment in manhattan and
all of a sudden this big eight hand hand
comes in and grabs
it then she's like
i'm suddenly like falling like 18
stories but he was holding her upside
down for a minute too like that he just
[ __ ] looks like he's just she's like
you're not just a dozer you [ __ ]
didn't put her back no
i mean you think but holy crap i mean
that i mean
for a movie that old that like horrified
me because i could imagine like
obviously i know giant ape isn't going
to reach in my window i don't think i
mean it's possible but i was just like
can you imagine like what that would be
like holy crap fay ray
um she kinda she does a good job in the
movie
did some iconic screaming
um she did all that screaming in one
session yeah
like she went in the sound booth and her
character is kind of like a typical arc
30s kind of
movie
young female
which is kind of like a lot like a
modern japanese girl you know like super
super family she's like that
um
physically she's [ __ ] cute real cute
um by the way that was a wig it was a
wig yeah because she wasn't they wanted
a blonde yeah and fay ray uh is not a
blonde okay uh if you've seen her in
because like i said she was also in the
most dangerous game i wasn't sure yeah
but yeah she wasn't they actually they
said they want to blonde because it
would stick out better like against
kong's fur because it's dark so they
actually wanted jean harlow
or somebody like that that was blonde
but they mostly turned it down so fay
ray like i said she had worked on
uh most dangerous game with the same
producers like prior to this and she's
like hey i can just wear a blonde wig
you know if you're that like a lot of
times a lot of times in the 30s uh the
girls that they'd have playing leads
where they're supposed to be kind of
like the love interest they're actually
kind of too skinny if you ask me they're
[ __ ] skinny kind of bony
um
or sometimes they you know
that was just what they but but faye was
kind of thick for the time it looks like
she had been working out or doing ballet
or something she they kept showing you
her legs to let you know that she had
muscular legs
but um
elegant looking she was cute um but she
would she could be a movie star today
she'd be you know what i mean yeah she's
a beauty she's beautiful beautiful i
wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't put her
great screamer too yeah great screamer
she was her
makeup and hair and the clothes are all
kind of you know silver 1930s you know
classic i guess you call it silver
silver screen
um
which just kind of has that look kind of
classy look
but you were to put her in modern
clothing you'd never know she could be a
movie star today
which is good i honestly love how
because i've forgotten a lot of the
details about because like i said i've
seen pieces of this but i hadn't seen
the whole thing straight through like
since i was a kid so i had forgotten a
bunch of details about how feyre ended
up on the island
and andero her character's name is but
she's basically like she's not homeless
but she's poor so like she's stealing an
apple like from a fruit seller like on
the sidewalk man yeah because it's
during the depression yeah and carl
denham happens to see her and is like
hey you want to be in my movie yeah but
like the first thing about it he takes
her to get like some food or something
because she's obviously like having some
problems like financially
and yeah i love that he's like pitching
to her he's like yeah we're gonna yeah
i'm gonna put you in the movies and all
this other kind of [ __ ] with a whole
bunch of sailors with a whole bunch of
sailors and immediately
wait hang on you want me to like get
with the gang bangs yeah you say that
but that's exactly what they're doing
that's what the implication was anything
like no it's all the up and up it's
something like i swear it's only up and
up i wouldn't buy it though still
because that's like
i mean back in the 1930s maybe it was a
more innocent time i guess that was
going on though but well yeah i know
that but i'm just saying that in a movie
people would maybe buy it i think the
reason that she went along with it was
because she'd heard of him because he's
like hey i'm carl denham like i'm a
movie maker
so i'm not
i guess we have to assume that when she
agreed she signed contracts in their
illegal contracts and documents after
that but they didn't put that in the
movie
yeah but that would be really boring
yeah that'd be boring but there was so
but the whole thing about it though i
imagine by the time she got on the on
the on the boat she knew who it was she
was dealing with and where she was going
i would hope so yeah because she seemed
real kind of like cash about it and
she's just kind of like okay we're gonna
yeah this is so exciting we're going on
a ship i've never been on once like that
might have been the way it was like well
they did mention that uh uh
well remember how towards the end when
they were in new york they're saying oh
another gorilla the girl goes over new
york's phil gorillas yeah i'm talking
about all the guys were gorillas and
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
and uh then she's like yeah this is
nothing that i and then another dude
made a wise crack in the [ __ ]
audience that the women were all the new
york women were all [ __ ] basically was
that's what that's what the uh that yeah
yeah pretty much and another complaint
he's that he spent 20 bucks on these
tickets and we're probably saying yeah
it's probably like 200 or 250 bucks but
yeah how much was i meant to check and
then i forgot but yeah how much was 20
bucks yeah when they first brought kong
to new york city i paid 20 bucks for
these tickets and i was like man that
was a lot of money back in 1933 we got
all during the depression rich old lady
says it's go we're going to see a
gorilla she goes ah you know basically i
you know she wasn't too impressed but
they were all dressed to the nines you
know and this is some real expensive
theater new york
probably probably a real theater but i
don't know what its name would be yeah
it was on broadway somewhere bro and uh
you know there was no tv then you know
[ __ ] you had to go see a show it was
a big [ __ ]
event
you know big social event you had to
dress up and
have your hair done and
jewelry and
you know in those days in the 30s
[ __ ] new york was the [ __ ] king of
the world i mean you know that was with
the biggest brightest biggest tallest
city probably in the world electric
power big tall skyscrapers
you had the damn
empire state building
that at that time was the tallest
building in the world
although i think chicago was probably
coming close to new york around that
same time
chicago and detroit were similar yeah at
that time
but uh so
it's kind of fitting that they took kong
there because that was the newest
high-tech city
they bring him there and he [ __ ] it up
well it just kills a bunch of people and
dies but
i mean you even know about airplanes
even now like the scene where he's at
the very top of the empire state
building and like with all the planes
that still stresses me out because like
i said i don't really i don't i don't
like heights yeah shooting him in the
neck and he's like what is this
i know he felt so bad yeah i mean i know
he ate a bunch of people and stomped on
a bunch of people and stuff like that
but like i said he's just like a big
really he doesn't know man
he's people are [ __ ] with him and
he's just like that's nowhere to go
that's just what he does and he's just
like you know what i mean it's like it's
kind of sad but um wait i wanted to like
say something like uh juan romero said
kong was the inspiration for all monster
movies that came after yeah pretty much
i mean
you could kind of say i don't know i
kind of feel like maybe some people said
it was like the first kaiju movie but
that's that's kind of like a slightly
different thing because kaiju movies are
usually
like radiation like cause this big like
super powered
creature whereas this was actually i
mean king kong was like a natural
creature and so skull island was just
kind of supposed to be like
um
you know it had dinosaurs like and
pterodactyls and [ __ ] like that so it
was kind of like supposed to be like a
lost world you know what i mean
best of the the the kaiju movies was
gujira the first one well yeah the black
and white one it was actually like a
serious film
gojira
they ended up calling it godzilla here
in the united states but that's not the
name of it
after that they started to get goofy but
yeah gojira is definitely based on kong
you know it's trying to be serious yeah
i mean the thing about like i said this
king kong didn't come out of nowhere it
kind of came out of the cultural like i
said there'd been a lot of these kind of
jungle movies which were really popular
um that were either just fictional
movies or documentaries or
mockumentaries and um
you also
you have to think too that back in the
20s and 30s
most
zoos and stuff like that didn't really
have like gorillas or primates or
anything like that so a lot of people in
the united states particularly had never
really seen
an ape or a gorilla
like in person
so there was kind of like a big
so it seemed like very exotic
now after this one there was another
movie i remember as a kid that used to
play it a lot i haven't seen it in a
long long time want to see it again
it was kind of like kong
but it it was a gorilla that was a hero
it was called mighty joe young well
that's the same producers yeah i want to
see that one again i remember liking
mighty joe young too yeah i liked that
as well i haven't seen it a long time
but he's a heroic gorilla and he's got a
girlfriend
basically well she's a trainer i don't
remember what happens to him
though i think he got killed too i think
been a long time it's that seated but i
liked it i remember liking mighty joe
young
yeah giant though he's just normal size
well i thought i saw him i thought he
was like a little bit a little bit
bigger than another he's not as big as
king kong no he might be about ten feet
tall i think yeah yeah juan says mighty
joe looks a lot more like a real gorilla
yeah yeah like king kong looks a little
weird but like i said he was just i mean
that was stop motion animation you have
to think this is the first movie
that had an entire character
that was entirely stop motion right uh
this was also i don't know if you guys
know but this was also the first movie
that had like a custom
written score like an orchestral score
prior to this because you have to think
this in 1933 so you know talkies hadn't
really been around for that long but
prior to this you just used like stock
music
uh behind the movies but when they were
doing this one they had the guy that did
the um the music was kind of like oh you
know maybe we could do music that
actually like matches up with the action
you know what i mean which hadn't been
done before
so that's what i mean when i say that
this was like really groundbreaking in
more ways than just like the special
effects and the big monster and
everything like that it was also the
first movie
that had like a custom tailored score
that like went with all the stuff that
was happening rather than just using
like already kind of stock stuff out of
the library or whatever
juan says they used several different
puppets that were not identical so he
changes from scene to scene yeah they
did well they had a bunch of different
ones they had like a life-size
um
because i think that i think that king
kong was supposed to be like 18 feet
tall i think okay so um they had like a
life-size
head like head and chest yeah
which they used when he was popping
people in his mouth and whatnot and then
they had a life-size
hand and arm yeah and then they had a
life-sized foot yeah he was stomping
people yeah all the other stuff were
like were miniatures and they were
usually they said they would usually do
like an inch to a foot so they were like
18 inches so they had like several 18
inch like armature ones now the thing
about king kong though is that back in
the day i mean willis o'brien was
somebody said earlier he was the man
yeah i mean ray harryhausen saw this
movie when he was a kid and he's like
that's what i want to do i want to do
that stop motion animation [ __ ] so thus
sinbad right
so i mean yeah so it's like i said it's
really hard to overstate like how uh
groundbreaking these special effects
were for the time and how
you know time consuming and like
painstaking they were
that they had like all of these little
because it wasn't just the king kong but
it was like all the dinosaurs and [ __ ]
like that too they had like the fair
pterodactyl and all the dinosaurs and
the snake and all that i remember when i
was a kid it was a smorgasbord monster
movie every [ __ ] scene there when
they're on that island you had something
to see something new was gonna come
pterodactyls
brontosauruses
stegosaurus they had some other giant
stuff didn't they there was a giant bug
no that was that was in the remakes like
i said there was a giant spider scene
but it was cut out okay and i think they
lost the footage and somebody mentioned
that in the peter jackson remake they
actually did an homage to that like
where they did it
but
that's well that's the thing because i
think what happened with this
this came out in 1933 it's original run
that was pre-code like pre-haze code
now because it was so successful they
kept re-releasing it like every few
years
they re-released it in 1938 and by then
the haze code had come in so they cut a
bunch out
so
after that like from the late 1930s i
think until the 1960s if i'm not
mistaken
um you saw like a truncated version of
king kong because they cut a bunch of
stuff out like a lot of like human
people like the chewing people and like
where the brontosaurus ate the dude like
on the tree and [ __ ] like that like all
the real uh you know the them squishing
the dudes and [ __ ] so they took all that
out because they thought it was too
violent oh and also the part where you
know where he's like poking at fay ray
and then sniffs his fingers yeah they
took that part out too okay yeah
so um so they took all that [ __ ] out one
of the one of the oh it didn't mean good
but then there's something that's creepy
in it but okay good yeah but but in the
1960s they actually found that in the uk
there was an uncut like a high quality
like uncut version where all that stuff
hadn't been cut out so from then on they
actually restored all the footage to the
american one but the spider one isn't
there no because that was cut out like
early on like before they released it
the first time
um i don't know if they thought it
didn't look good or they just thought it
was too much or it wasn't or it didn't
look good and i don't really know what
they what it was they were just kind of
like uh they just cut it out i think
before even like the original one of the
things she was talking about cutting out
the violence one of the things that was
in there and this one that i don't
really remember was the it was kind of a
creepy scene where they got the the the
the tribal girl that they're gonna
sacrifice
and they got her
kneeling on a mat and she's like [ __ ]
yeah she had her eyes
that's big and they're putting flowers
on her and [ __ ] [ __ ] it was it was
kind of creepy great because she's like
i'm gonna die they're giving me the calm
[ __ ] you know
and then uh the the the guy they're
calling the witch doctor if i could see
his fade he says well no no we'll trade
for her the golden one yeah he's never
seen one of them he's getting bored of
these
it's like that's a good one let's take
that one yeah they were going to give
like 30 women for
you know which yeah they they might do
something like that that's a new one
we're going to give him one of these new
ones that'll buy us a lot of time
because if you look at the damn wall
that they built
it was pretty sophisticated
and it definitely been there a long time
so i imagine it sucked up a lot of
resources to keep [ __ ] kong back on
his side of the island
so if you gave him something you could
buy yourself time
yeah keep him from crashing keep him
from crashing through and you can
because he did that eventually so yeah
so he couldn't get through it if he
really wanted to they were up on the
damn battlements fighting him with
spears and [ __ ] they got [ __ ]
annihilated yeah
but they jumped right in there and they
just jumped in there to fight him yeah
i mean you know
like saving their countries
almost all the white dudes got killed
yeah
even though they had guns and bombs in
there yeah they eventually cast him
knocked him out and knocked him out yeah
i kind of like
i was uh interestingly i was gonna say
too that like actually the first draft
of the script of this
was written by the very famous
british mystery writer edgar wallace who
i actually i've actually read a couple
of his uh things because his uh stories
were the basis of a couple of like
giallo movies like what have you done to
solange and stuff
so he wrote the first draft of this
which was called the beast
um but he died before they could finish
it up so it went through a lot of other
iterations now interestingly
the main version as well as like the
title because originally the title for
this like i said it was first the beast
then it was going to be called the
eighth wonder or the eighth wonder of
the world which is not a great title but
whatever
um but when they brought in
uh ruth rose who was actually the wife
of one of the producers ernest shedsack
and she had never written a screenplay
before
but they gave her the screenplay and
said see what you can do with that and
she like tightened it all up and she
like uh took out a bunch of the dialogue
changed up a bunch of the dialogue like
made it a lot better
and she basically um
like they were really into like what she
did with it and one of the things that i
liked that she did was
you know how like they do the whole
thing where they gas kong
they're like wait i'm gonna take this to
new york city we're gonna make a million
dollars or whatever
and then they just cut to them like
already thing she's like the original
version of the script actually had them
like oh doing like the logistics of them
like how did we get them like off this
island to new york city and she was like
[ __ ] all that we don't need to see all
that he they got him to new york somehow
that's boring so it's like she just kind
of like streamlined it right too and i
like that they did that that they didn't
do all that unnecessary
kind of like [ __ ] about that there
was some hidden messaging in there that
might have been lost on
younger generations especially modern
generations um having to do with those
airplanes
they took kong from his homeland all
right they said he will learn to fear us
we have technology
to take him to new york trade him up
treat him like [ __ ]
humiliating him he gets out they can't
control him he gets out kills a bunch of
people runs to the top of the empire
state building the guys at the bottom
says what we can do now no we'll get him
with those what do you call them
airplanes yeah we'll get them with some
airplanes that's right oh yeah airplanes
i forgot we had those
it hadn't been around for all that long
that's true that's true this is after
world war one yeah
so they sent airplanes they call
and you're supposed to realize how
unfair that is he's getting shot in the
throat and he's looking he's you know
what i mean he gets one of what's going
on yeah what's going on and then he gets
one airplane but they gunned him down
well
this is before world war ii
the people haven't really kind of
realized how much warfare has changed in
world war one the turks showed up a
cavalry
to the battle
space
an enemy fighter planes just ch chewed
them up with machine guns wiped them out
and they were like this isn't fair this
isn't warfare you're cheating
you know warfare changes constantly
so that's kind of the message
that warfare is cheating
you know
and kong didn't know how to cheat he was
kind of honest
human beings are kind of dishonest they
cheated they didn't go down there on the
ground and fight him you know man-to-man
and uh so that was part of the tragedy
that you're supposed because you know
you're supposed to feel sorry for him
well yeah and i think everybody i mean
unless you're a sociopath you're right
um when you watch king kong yeah you
feel bad when he does it then i felt bad
i think everybody felt so the message
was is uh yeah the white man kind of won
in the end but it was a pyrrhic victory
you dishonored yourself you had to cheat
to do it yeah that's what that's that's
what i kind of feel like that's probably
why the movie one was such a classic
even though i don't think that people
would necessarily think that that was
why but i think that's why it's kind of
like endured for this long as well
because like you said it almost does
like have a weird
animal rights message and i don't even
think that they'd meant to do that
necessarily i think they were just
trying to make like a cool like jungle
adventure fantasy story they're trying
to put realism in there and make
characters and trying to do that but the
right way you know but i kind of feel
like i mean maybe they were i don't know
it was a long time ago but i kind of
feel like accidentally they were just
kind of like hey maybe we shouldn't [ __ ]
with things that we don't understand or
it's like we're we're going into a part
of the world that we don't really have
any
business in like we don't you know well
jog boy said beauty killed the beast no
he didn't [ __ ] machine guns killed it
from airplanes that's what i'm saying i
was like she didn't have [ __ ] she did it
right yeah she was just pretty and he
liked her right
and i think the audiences of the time
kind of understood what what what the
real message was i'm like no you [ __ ]
killed and you killed him by bringing
him here because [ __ ] [ __ ] it kong
was the hero of the move he really
i mean i think he was the star of the
movie and i think people liked carl
where they want to see kong again
yeah and uh you know they had something
like they said he didn't and people
liked him and then mighty joe young is
definitely the hero and mighty joe young
yeah okay so
like i said it just seemed to me that
unless you have some kind of like
empathy problem
i kind of feel like you're supposed to
feel bad at the end of king kong yeah
you know because
he didn't do anything to deserve that
it's like yeah he ate some people yeah
he stomped on some people but he's an
animal
you know what i mean it's like he
was just doing what he did that was his
nature and it's like yeah it's bad for
us and it's like bad that it that he ate
people and stuff but he doesn't know any
different
and so the fact that people that
absolutely did
know better
came in there and were like hey we can
exploit this for money
and took him to a place where he
you know didn't belong
and he [ __ ] it all up
he pulled that woman out of the thing
that i don't know that that really like
stressed me out that whole [ __ ] scene
and the whole [ __ ] scene where he
climbs up the outside of the empire
simply like i've been up the empire
state building
and
um
i did not like it thank you i mean i i
felt like i had to i was like i'm going
to new york city i was like you kind of
have to go up the empire state building
right it's like you can't say that
you've gone to new york without going up
there so i went up there
but
i like i said i am terrified terrified
of heights so i went up there and i just
like i very slowly like i hung on to
like the [ __ ] like all the way to the
thing i'm like looked over i'm like okay
i've done it bye let's go i'm please let
me go down back to the ground now so
yeah that stresses me out so it stresses
me out when i see it in a movie and [ __ ]
too
uh john gore said son of kong is pretty
weak they made
his air small simply to all the humans
and all around silly yeah well i mean we
should probably watch that as well
because i haven't seen it since i was a
kid
but
i remember liking mighty joe young
though
but i haven't seen it in a long time
juan says
um
i remember vaguely i saw that when i was
a kid too i remember liking it
i remember it being a little more more
positive
you know it's kind of more of upbeat but
we'll see i haven't seen it a long time
yeah uh juan says i like how ann never
gets lovey-dovey with kong at any point
like in the remake yeah i mean she
didn't
i guess i'd kind of like forgotten
because i've seen so many of like the
remakes and the subsequent um kind of
commentary in the film but in the
original movie she's not like into kong
at all she's just like oh my god it's a
monster and like she's just screaming
and trying to get away from him the
whole entire time she's not like oh he's
kind of sexy you know what i mean where
i kind of feel like in the window well
no like the remake
70s remake well the 70s remake and the
um the 2000s remake
i don't like she wasn't like ooh sexy
big ape but she felt like sympathy with
him yeah where i feel like in the
original film she didn't really she just
kind of like saw him as a monster yeah
yeah you know what i mean maybe maybe
she felt well from their point of view
sure
like but i mean maybe she felt bad like
at the very end like when he fell off
the building and was dead and everybody
was protecting her yeah he thought he
was protecting her remember like he was
protecting her from from the uh
from the uh pterodactyls the giant
pterodactyls yeah he thought he was
protecting her because holy [ __ ] oh that
was another [ __ ] scene that stressed
me out like when she was up on the on
the uh kind of ridge there and the
pterodactyls came and like started
carrying around like oh my god
oh my god it was fighting something else
at the time i remember what it was well
he was fighting the snake inside the
cave
and then yeah then the pterodactyl came
while it's like yeah he was distracted
while he was distracted he got that yeah
the um and he had to pull that down i
remember in one of the remakes she was
dancing for him to uh keep that was one
of the newer remakes
dancing for him to keep stay on his good
side that worked
he was watching her [ __ ]
i mean i kind of i kind of feel like we
watched
how long ago did we watch the 1976 one
no it wasn't that long ago a year ago
maybe it was maybe like a year ago i
think we were living here though weren't
we
that's what i'm saying i thought we
watched it like pretty recently i
thought we watched it like six months
ago
it's not bad i remember seeing that at
the drive it was okay
when i was a kid and we didn't age that
well the the you can do it you know it's
definitely a dude in a suit
walking around a bunch of miniatures
but i don't remember it looking that
obvious back in the uh back in the days
no before and the thing about the
original king kong is that at no point
is it a man in a suit right it is always
stop motion animation and in a way i
think that kind of makes it work a lot
better i think
i mean and all the dinosaurs and [ __ ]
work too because the thing about it was
that
i don't even know if they were initially
gonna have dinosaurs in it i think the
original concept
was giant ape fights komodo dragons yeah
that was the original concept the reason
they went with dinosaurs was because the
studio like rko was also making this
other movie with stop-motion dinosaurs
that was called creation that was
costing them like a [ __ ] ton of money
and when the producers approached him
about the uh about the giant ape thing
he's like hey um let's cancel that
creation
dinosaur thing and we'll put the
dinosaurs and the guy that was making
the dinosaurs who was willis o'brien
into this movie
and we'll also use the jungle sets from
most dangerous games so he was trying to
like economize the old the only uh
kong spin-offs i remember really liking
was kong skull island i wanted to get
that on blu-ray and i i never got around
to it i liked kong skull island
um
the godzilla remakes i remember enjoying
them in the theater but i couldn't tell
anything about them they were [ __ ]
vapid it was just vapid [ __ ] cg
fightings of big [ __ ] dinosaurs and
it didn't matter which i mean i'm not
averse to like monster fights i like
that kind of stuff to you but the skull
island i like that one the best out of
them that one was the most fun i felt
like that was the most fun yeah camp guy
said is that one with jack black yeah
jack black was in that one right yeah i
remember being okay i remember it being
it was i remember it being pretty fun
yeah juan says uh rick baker did the
suit in the 76 remake uh it's a decent
suit yeah but i mean you can still tell
it's a suit you can still tell but the
thing about it though
and like i said i saw that in the
drive-in
when i was a kid i think it was maybe
second run so i probably saw it when i
was i don't know seven eight something
like that and i remember really liking
it but
we watched it a few months ago yeah
probably like six months ago or
something like that
it's still good but i was just i was
surprised by how much like uh
slow [ __ ] there was in it before
and honestly the original king kong it's
an hour and 40 minutes which i feel like
was i don't know was that long for
movies in the 30s i feel like they were
shorter back then
but
man it doesn't it doesn't [ __ ] around i
mean it's pretty much everything
every single scene is necessary
um you know it it basically just starts
out with the filmmaker and he's like hey
i'm looking for like a dame for my movie
or whatever
and uh you know and then pretty much
they get on the ship and then there's
like so there's always like something
going on it's like pretty action-packed
and as i said as once they get to the
island man there's some great scenes big
monster fights like i said still my
favorite scene and i just and i love the
way it was shot i love
love
[ __ ] king kong
shaking all those dudes off along that
is and they're all like screaming if i
was like holy [ __ ] yeah he's killing
everybody yeah he's killing everybody
yeah it was good how they how they did
it because he's stop motion but he's
moving a real miniature log yeah and
no actually he's moving in real long and
there's real dudes on it and then in
other shots i think it's uh
some claymation guys on a miniature but
but the transitions in are are pretty
slick
the easter egg is seen a different thing
you can tell it's not real but it looks
good
i mean they used so many
um
just techniques in that in this that
hadn't been used before
and the way that they combined them i
mean yeah it looks quote unquote crude
by today's standards it was the 19
[ __ ] 30s that was almost a century
ago the shots are artistic yeah and
honestly it still looks really good i
was really amazed like watching it you
know with a kind of critical special
effects eye i mean
i i'm going to say like all that it's
always going to look
you know even the shittiest stop motion
i think is going to look better than
like shitty cgi oh yeah much better
i mean well um there's a charm too that
classic kong movie is it's it's it's
artwork it's a classic work of art
yeah and it looks great it looks good
yeah i mean all the jungle shots like i
said that such depth of field like i
said because it's all like this map
paintings on glass that looks fantastic
you're just supposed to enjoy it and it
wouldn't be as good in color you want it
to be in black and white do you want it
to take you into the past that's what it
does did any [ __ ] ever try to
like colorize that they probably
john gore said cgi has no magic i mean
cgi has its place yeah but see fury road
yeah
see to me like fury road that's cgi done
right i think the only time that you
should use cgi is just to clean up stuff
that's mostly practical
if you can do it in camera do it in
camera cgi the cgi in fury road they
used real cars they were really jumping
off of [ __ ]
everything's really there but they're
using cgi to get rid of tire tracks in
the sand
from earlier takes
they're using cgi to get rid of safety
harnesses and wires that are [ __ ]
because some of those guys are jumping
from car to car they're on a safety wire
i mean i would hope so because otherwise
they'd get [ __ ] killed not in the old
road
warrior they just [ __ ]
jumped onto the [ __ ] truck you know
am i insured okay yeah but you know
legal problems so they but that that's
really how you should do it
yeah
but that's the thing i don't i'm not a
big fan of and you know it's a lot
better nowadays i guess but i'm not a
big fan of like um
complete characters that are created out
of cgi because it never quite looks real
no now some people have said well that
when that rolling
um [ __ ] concert truck crash that was
cgi no it's not no it wasn't it's it's
real it's just that they saw all the
behind the scenes [ __ ] that was
absolutely frame rate that was
absolutely and the flames the flames
coming out of the guitar was not cg it's
real that thing really did split and
they just used color treatment on it it
looked a little redder it looks super
red
but it's it's that's real flame it's a
real flamethrower
yeah and like i said i don't have a
problem with like cleaning stuff up
afterward or doing color grading or like
adding little touches here and there
but i think the problem arises when
you're creating entire
characters or creating entire backdrops
or landscapes and stuff like that in cgi
it just doesn't look as good i feel like
and like i said they weren't doing it i
mean back in the old days yeah they shot
stuff on sound stages and like a lot of
times for backgrounds they'd use
matte paintings but at least somebody
like actually painted that you know
that's like a piece of art
and i'm not saying you know i don't know
i'm not saying that like computer stuff
isn't a work of art too but i don't know
it just doesn't look as good
it doesn't look as yeah john john goris
brings up
how um lou ferrigno is gonna always be
better than the damn cgi hulk you're
right lou ferrigno [ __ ] to me is the
[ __ ] hulk all right
that's the thing when you get a dude who
was really standing there and [ __ ]
lou was that big
well see that's the problem yeah the
character yeah he had lou
the lou ferrigno
hulk had facial expressions that were
you were real and you knew that was a
real dude and he's going back down to
normal and [ __ ] you know he's calming
down he's going back to turning back
into [ __ ] bill bixby
when you're a kid you know and and you
could watch it today and it's better
it's better when you're a kid you're
just immersed in that experience because
yeah i know i know how you feel and how
you feel i do the same thing when i get
mad i turn green too you know that kind
of [ __ ]
[Music]
when i get mad i get that size too
[Laughter]
i should have never done it and never
did you wrong you know
they deserved it
juan says i never thought stop motion
looked real but it always looked cool
and that's the point yeah yeah exactly
that's why people still talk about ray
harryhausen to this day that's why
people still talk about willis o'brien
to this day because yeah it doesn't look
real but it's just cool it's stylized
it's a movie
you know what you're getting into
there's a lot of stuff in in uh mad max
and road warrior that doesn't look real
but it looks cool it was done with edits
you know like the guy's eyes popping out
that was just all edited in there it
doesn't look real it's just [ __ ]
the editing the timing of it the way
everything's ha you know happening
it just looks cool yeah i mean it
doesn't have to look real yeah there's
something i mean a lot of it was real
but there's some of it that wasn't real
just you know
editing it together into into a [ __ ]
into a work of art that something that
brings emotion out of you yeah using
visual stimulation juan says absolute
perfection is boring exactly exactly
something has to have like some
character or some interest yeah just
like
like those early 80s movies and 70s
movies were like that with limited
budgets but a lot yeah i think that's
kind of why i like a lot of that stuff
like and i'm not saying that i don't
like movies nowadays because i do but
the movies that i tend to like nowadays
tend to be ones that are more like
independent or don't have a lot of
special effects like a lot of ones that
are real um you know heavy on the
visuals or heavy on like the spectacle
some of them i like but a lot of them
are just kind of like they're good but
they're just kind of samey they don't
really stand out they don't really have
a lot of character that's well we saw a
low-budget movie that was [ __ ] great
about post-apocalyptic movie about the
the little person and and the woman they
were the last soul survivor yeah what's
the name of that thing i forgot the name
of that yeah we just did that and i like
that and uh there wasn't anything i
think we're alone now i think we're
alone now yeah you like that like that
uh song yeah that's a great little
post-apocalyptic movie almost kind of
like not as wacky as boy and his dog but
it kind of had darkness to it but i
liked it but just goes to show
you can make him money you can make a
movie with no money i mean it doesn't
have to be spectacle
you know what i'm saying everything
doesn't have to be like superheroes
punching each other and looking big like
you know that's an atmosphere that's
cool but
i mean just give me like an interesting
story or like characters i give a [ __ ]
about or something like that you don't
need all that you don't need all those
bells and whistles usually just a movie
filmed in empty
kind of abandoned places and
empty houses and
empty [ __ ]
towns you know i saw a good one today
that actually i'm gonna put up a review
for it later this week uh it came out in
2017. it's like i don't want to call it
a horror movie it's actually more of a
psychological thriller i guess
um and it was called super dark times
have any of you guys seen that but it
was actually kind of like
that was another one that i don't think
was like super uh had much of a budget
or anything like that but
man that like it [ __ ] kept me on the
edge of my seat the whole entire time
like i said you don't really need a lot
of money if you know what you're doing
if it's a good story and i'm like into
the characters and i give a [ __ ] about
what happens to them you don't need like
big [ __ ] monsters fighting and stuff
like that now that i'm averse to that i
do like that sometimes but
i i will take like artistic
like a cool stylized looking thing or
like some
cool characters and show like that like
every time so i think that's why i like
a lot of those old like stop-motion
movies
i like a lot of movies from like the
1930s i like a lot of silent movies
even though obviously by today's
standards like the special effects are
you know really rudimentary if you want
to say that
but they had like some [ __ ] style to
them and i like to kind of like cast
myself back to that time period being
like man what would people of that time
have thought like when they saw this
movie like that this must have been like
really like [ __ ] mind-blowing which
is what we i said that last night we
were watching king kong i was just like
man people must have [ __ ] [ __ ] a
brick when they saw this thing because
it was
yeah special effects have been done like
i've seen movies from like the late
1800s that had like trick camera effects
and stuff in them
um you know george mellier did a bunch
of that stuff but
nothing that had been done like to this
extent you know what i'm saying where
they used like so many
uh different techniques and like they
had a whole character that was stop
motion and you know just i don't know it
just seemed like it was this big like
milestone in movie making history i feel
like this is one of those movies that
you absolutely have to see yeah
that's probably about all we can say
about this though i think i mean
probably i don't think there are any um
hatfield said uh pat hatfield actually
said earlier that um
that he enjoyed mighty joe young a
little bit better than the original i
remember liking it better than i
remember liking it but i haven't seen it
in a long time
um pat hatfield also said superheroes
punching each other is losing its charm
because you see it so often yeah i think
one of the main problems that i have and
this is it's becoming less of a problem
as cgi gets better but one of the
problems that i had with some of the um
like superhero movies and stuff like
that is because they can't ever capture
motion
correctly it's always like just too fast
it's a little bit too fast and too
weightless and it always just like it
really really sticks out to me the last
spider-man was pretty good
yeah i will say that i did like the last
bite all the the all the spider-man's in
the same movie that was pretty good
uh even they even brought back the damn
the goblin
he was it was good to see him back they
had all the damn
bad guys that was a pretty good one um
but a lot of that [ __ ] just
it's too much man
too much
yeah i don't know like i said i would
kind of rather i mean zach just said
that's why i love movies from the 70s so
much because they have a lot of
character and personality filmmaking you
don't see too much anymore i kind of
feel like they're generic well i mean i
feel like the 70s in particular was kind
of like late 60s to late 70s was kind of
like the haiti of like the auteur
where you know you had these big
directors that were kind of given a free
hand to do whatever they wanted and i
think that usually yes i know every film
is like a you know a group effort
because a lot of people have to work on
it but i kind of feel like if you have
just one really strong like artistic
vision
i think that usually works out like and
i think it's better if that vision is
like really idiosyncratic because it's
really like
you know the the personality of like the
director comes out a lot of those marvel
superhero movies
uh
they're very generic they're kind of
like a watered-down generic ride at
disneyland
there's not a lot of content in there
you know they show you a bunch of stuff
a lot of stuff happens
but there's not a lot of meaning to it
to me
it's not very weighty like all that
should happen be like yeah so what
and i think it's because the way the
studios operate jenny mentioned it
earlier there's a lot of cooks in the
kitchen
so if somebody says something or if
there's if you have one message you have
to have another message and another
message and another message and
so i think what the deal is is that they
start to kind of strip as
much of the [ __ ] intellectual con
content out of the story as possible
um
therefore that there isn't any conflicts
in the messaging
well and plus they're trying to make
everybody happy because they want
everybody to go see it and like it and
you're just never gonna it's just gonna
be so the best way to make everybody
happy is not to have any kind of message
per se
uh it's just a big spectacle like a ride
like a ride at disneyland it doesn't
really mean anything but they look at
i'd look behind me and all these [ __ ]
people just geeking out on it like it's
uh
like it's a cult you know and
like there's seeing the gods or
something like they're really buying
into it and i'm like going yeah it's
kind of empty spectacle you know so what
well i mean the thing about it though is
that i don't want to like [ __ ] anybody's
fandom because some people do like kind
of follow all those characters in the
comics and they're interested to like
see how the movies and some people like
really are into all those movies so i'm
not like super super into that but
i mean i geek out about other things
that i'm sure other people would think
were completely lame so i'm not going to
get too much like well i see the thing
is is that i can understand geeking out
on harry potter
because there's at least a bunch of
books and a bunch of characters that do
things and they they say things and they
talk
in those marvel movies there's not a lot
of character [ __ ] going on really
there's not a lot of story
really there is story but it's very
simple
um it's mostly spectacle
yeah i mean i don't know you know i mean
so i i don't really i can't get any kind
of emotional connection to it that's
what i'm saying like i said i'm you know
i'm i don't care that iron man punch
that other dude i don't give a [ __ ] you
know
some people care but it's like i don't
really i don't really i've seen some of
the movies but i haven't like seen all
of them and so i'm not really like into
all the character arcs and everything
like that so because like i said i'm
more of a horror girl those first couple
seasons of daredevil were [ __ ]
fantastic
i mean that that's how you do it
but there was a lot because it was a
smaller story smaller stories a lot of
writing and a lot of smaller story
because i kind of feel like the bigger
you get yeah like the more like the less
you can relate to it yeah the less you
can relate to it like the less an
average person can really do it i kind
of tend to like
i'm not you know what and even though i
really like horror and stuff like that i
tend to like not like
more um like real big world building
kind of stuff like i'm not even really
all that into like lord of the rings or
anything like that i can see how people
are
but once things get past a certain where
it goes like epic scale i'm just kind of
like i start like losing interest by
degrees i kind of feel like i like more
intimate stories
where it's just like a handful of
characters that i can actually like give
a [ __ ] about and what are they up to
when it gets to be this whole like world
thing i think that's kind of why i'm not
super into like big zombie apocalypse
movies or things like that because it
just seems like i was like that's too
much
i don't know it's just too much to like
keep a handle on it once i'm not like
super into it i can see how other people
are but yeah pat i saw the animated spot
into the spider verse i saw that one
that was really good that was fantastic
i liked that a lot that's not the one i
was talking about you were talking about
uh homecoming i think no was it
homecoming or no way home
something like that
where um the latest one yeah
the new spider-man the newest one he
hooked up with uh doctor strange and he
had he had him trying to reverse
people's memory or some [ __ ] like then
it caused all kinds of death
problems in the space time continuum and
bad guys started showing up from [ __ ]
the spider-man universe and then uh you
know
all the other spider-mans from the
[ __ ] live-action movies showed up
you know toby mcguire spider-man showed
up i just thought that was a great movie
i liked it yeah that was a lot of fun i
had a lot of fun with it it was because
like like jenny's saying the universe
wasn't that big i know that that's
that's only a few characters and they
had movies that backed those characters
up where certain things happened so
that's pretty good but some of that
marvel universe stuff there's so many
characters that each one of them is in
there only like a few seconds at a time
well they're trying to cram so many
story lines into one like that you can't
concentrate on one yeah like i said i
tend to like more intimate stories where
i can concentrate on just like a handful
of characters and like what they're up
to yeah like when you're trying to like
build this whole world and it's like
you know it's really hard for like
me to care about
all this other stuff we announced what
haunting we're watching tonight uh we
did not somebody asked like a long time
ago and i meant to we are going to be
watching what did we decide echoes of
the pop that goes
right okay he doesn't want it echoes of
the past we're going to play i'm going
to make an announcement too if i
remember like i'll make an announcement
either tonight or tomorrow because i
know that a lot of you guys have said
you know when we do a haunting mondays
it's like that you wanted us to announce
which ones we were gonna watch so so you
could watch them too like so you could
like follow along so i'm pretty sure
we're gonna do echoes of the past
yeah
for tomorrow because tomorrow is
haunting if anything changes we'll post
it
yeah uh caleb says good news is we got
a24 in blumhouse creating new original
small films yeah and i mean there's so
many like i said i'm i'm into horror so
there's so many like independent photo i
see
amazing horror movies like pretty much
weekly like from just independent
filmmakers
so you can get that [ __ ] a la carte well
i mean the thing about it though i well
i don't know i just kind of feel like i
see when new stuff comes out i try to
keep up with
you know what's everybody talking about
nowadays like what's the what's the good
new [ __ ] like on all those streaming
services like shutter or whatever and so
you know but i've seen like so many good
honestly like in the last year or two
i've seen like some [ __ ] amazing
horror movies that were just like
independent movies or like there were
like people's first movies and [ __ ] like
that so you know
yeah it passed in the ceiling new
spider-man but it sounds like yeah it's
good the new the new spider-man live
action was good
it's got all the old bad guys from the
toby maguire ones are in it
toby maguire shows up
some of the other spiderman show up
from other movies because doctor doctor
strange [ __ ] up the damn space time
continuum so the it becomes a live
action multiverse
kind of like into the spider spider
versus all the damn cartoon ones
yeah or all in one
this is all it's like that but it's
always like it was like all the live
action ones now what i was hoping at the
time i'm watching is wait a minute is
this is the car is the animated sp uh
villains uh spider-man going to show up
that would have been the only thing that
would have made it even better it would
have been even better
than like [ __ ] cartoon town and [ __ ]
because i wanted to see spider-gwen show
up it would have been yeah it would it
would have been like who framed roger
yeah be like
which [ __ ] that's another movie we need
to review did you ever see who framed
roger a time ago oh man that movie is so
good i saw that in the theater pat uh
pat hatfield said you should watch
revealer on shutter okay i will um i
don't think i have my paper but i'll
write it down in a second
uh
two million yeah 2b and shutter awesome
streaming services
yeah they are i mean 2b
i we have shutter we've had shutter
forever and i love
um
to be is actually like amazing and it's
free like there's ads and stuff but
um
they have a [ __ ] ton they have a [ __ ]
ton of horror on there old [ __ ] new [ __ ]
yeah you gotta wait like their search
leaves a little bit to be desired but
they have um so many classics on there
that you can watch and they have a bunch
of new [ __ ] too there's a lot of like
bad new [ __ ] like that's you know
uh stuff that you have to wade through
but
if you know what you're looking for um a
lot of times they'll have it so you know
what i mean
let's see who else they're talking about
um
pat said i saw a wild movie on tv
yesterday called muscle car
yeah but the one i was talking about
earlier uh super dark times is actually
on 2b as well it's also on hulu and i
think it's on the roku channel as well
but that's actually like a really good
movie but i'm going to put up a review
of it later so i don't want to talk too
much about it but
are we ready to
sign off all right so tomorrow is a
haunting monday and we're going to watch
echoes of the past so if you want to
watch along with us that's where we're
gonna i don't know i don't remember what
season or episode it is but it's called
echoes of the past that's what we're
gonna watch tonight and we're gonna be
talking about that tomorrow so thanks
for hanging out with us on this sunday
evening and we will see you guys again
tomorrow
bye